sì ho capito ma sponsorizzano sto zaino
che se noi ragazzi non lo vedono e ne
sanno che il tuo originale poi magari lo
vedono in giro e pensano che sia un
tarocco colpito zio ma che cosa mi cei
non solo una per cento era capito che
non so cosa fare non è che mi vengono
idee qualcosa
capito salve terra tutti ragazzi e
benvenute vi sono io sono bella tutti
ragazzi e benvenute nessun video sono
parigi oggi siamo tornati in un nuovo
blog alle luglio grazie a dio sono
riuscito a fare una intro decente
questa settimana è successa la cosa
della vita l'avrete già detto dal titolo
lo so però qualche per il fatto che
mettere giulia penna in fa vj nello
stesso tiki cosa non ancora non hai
fatto ritardo di porto e da slow food
sto facendo zio te lo giuro non sto
facendo
smetterà di chiamarmi porca vacca ha già
fatto
[Musica]
capitolo veri grazia zio
non ho parole allora ragazzi sia l'anno
scorso ma anche quest'anno lo zaino
intanto sta roba in metallo la potete
dare in testa gli haters l'ho fatto io
non c'era il senso mi sono messo lì a
cucire ogni singolo zaino ed è venuto
fuori e questo è molto molto carico che
sono detto io mettete questa cosa qui
mettete il televisore qui mettete questo
coso di ambigua forma qui in alto a
sinistra quindi l'ho fatto io il design
chi non se lo prende un buffo passiamo
ragazzi e al prossimo punto che è quello
che è stato aspettando credo tutti
questa settimana con tudor abbiamo fatto
un video dovrebbe che abbiamo fatto uno
scherzo telefonico a dei miei amici tra
cui giulia penna il video di tudor lo
trovate nella descrizione delle di
questo video perché ve lo lascio molto
bello vi lascerò in questo blog
lo scherzo che io e tudor abbiamo fatto
che io ho fatto tu non sta a fancazzo
sarà col telefono che hanno fatto a
giulia penna te la faccio breve per chi
non conoscesse giulia penna vigilia
piena abbiamo partecipato al videoclip
di gabry ponte per la canzone tu sei nel
videoclip musicale ci siamo dati un
bacio dovevamo rappresentare questi due
ragazzi che si incontrano che si
innamorano che si danno un bacio alla
fine quindi era tutta una parte recitata
ovviamente e quindi lo scherzo
telefonico che abbiamo fatto a giulia
l'ho chiamata le ho detto guarda che
dobbiamo fare un altro video clip per
gabry ponte questa volta dobbiamo fare
una scena di sesso e questa è stata la
reaction vi lascia vido borghesiana non
ridere è stata difficile
ciao giulia senti ascolta io ti volevo
chiedere una cosa un parere così perché
sono un po titubante su una cosa che è
successa però ascolta perché una cosa
abbastanza importante cioè mi ha
chiamato mettiamo toga brino che è
praticamente cia
gli è venuto adesso sta fissa che c'è
questo nuovo pezzo che deve fare e mi fa
che vuole che noi facciamo un'altra
un'altra donna tra comparsata di un suo
video nuovo e mi fa che dobbiamo fare
una scena tipo tipo erotica mi ha detto
ma ha detto che aprì così ma ha detto te
lo giuro è infatti ero tipo e lo gli ho
detto niente che ho detto poco bel figo
e non so tu che ad esempio è già fatto
una cosa del genere come è stato da
robert julia cosa che spetta agli ho
visti chi mi dice se più per l'inzio di
un no perché io non so che cosa fare in
giornata di sport modo da sapere dove
insieme fino fino fino fino a 15
centimetri ok abe sentivamo che ci
riaggiorniamo fino a 20 dai fino a 20
vabbè comunque io tu mi hai dato parere
adesso capisco e poi ci riaggiorniamo di
richiamo io direttamente questa cosa ok
cosa deve dire anch'io
va bene ciao bella
io mi sento fare tutto questo come le ho
detto che un senso che bello che è belli
gli scherzi telefoni stato io
riguardavano i tempi quindi frank matano
quando ero piccolo tra l'altro mi
ricordo di i primi youtubers furono
daniele doesn't matter il primo forse in
assoluto io topi e frenata non si quando
frank non faceva le scoregge comunque
ragazzi mi hanno inviato insieme al allo
zaino perché lo zaino mi hanno inviato
quando l'hanno finito di produrre
malignato questo pack di cose sempre
brandizzate che mi dovrei che dovrebbero
uscire che dovresti trovare in giro non
so è che io e l'arresto ma le previste
c'è oltre allo zaino c'è anche tipo il
diario e robe del genere che ho sempre
fatto io e ho insistito come una bacca
per farlo fare morbido cioè nel senso
starebbe morbida terapico tastare il
morbido quindi ho insistito come un
puledro per farlo così ma mi hanno fatto
anche i quadernoni ad anelli grossi
quello più su questo rivediamo col
design
c'è un altro diario come se non bastasse
colori prima che per questa flessibile
tipo che molti e molto sexy
le cartelline anche a crescere col
design di prima questo sempre lo
ripetiamo è un ultimo ma non ultimo dei
quaderni
[Applauso]
basta vabbè ragazzi questo è tutto
quello che abbiamo fatto bocchio sono
sta roba che questa roba sia solida e
non disegnata perché se solida vuol dire
che originale cioè noi
i tarocchi il maruggio la mettono cucita
piccolo coi sandali e non è una cosa
davvero originale però se questo tipo va
così quindi ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto giulia non se l'è presa per
questa roba anche se non è ancora detto
che era uno scherzo proprio lei ancora
crede che sia vero e quindi io lo so
giulia che non vedevi l'ora di questa
cosa
i ragazzi spero che il video di oggi vi
sia piaciuto come se si vivesse un
commento non mi piace anche vari social
che il cammino diviso totale descrizione
se non siete più gli scritti iscrivetevi
ci vediamo ad un prossimo video dai
ragazzi nel telecomando
chiediamo un testo ho fatto ancora
vedere bei ragazzi
[Musica]